hey everybody how you doing i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message on march 3rd in the year
2022 subscribe on rumble subscribe on
youtube subscribe on blaze tv
etc and today ladies and gentlemen is
world book day it's hashtag
world book day and you're not gonna
believe it but i've got another book
coming out that's right don't burn this
country comes out on april 12th it is my
second book i think you're really really
gonna dig it it's sort of what i think
will be the second
of uh
three books a trilogy we had don't burn
this book don't burn this country you
might be able to figure out what i think
the title of the third book is going to
be but the first book really was laying
out all of my classically liberal
principles which in many ways in modern
context are conservative and libertarian
principles this is sort of how you can
put those principles into action and
what you can do
as the world kind of melts down to make
sure that you don't go crazy as the
world goes crazy so uh if you have not
pre-ordered already you can go to
daverubin.com
book and pre-order so you get the book
on april 12th you can we have all the
links there so you can get it from
barnes noble or amazon or your local
book seller
etc all that good stuff and by the way
if you pre-order all pre-orders count
as week one orders and i did get on the
new york times bestseller list because
we really crushed it obviously the new
york times does not want me
on there i would love to get on there
again not because i think the new york
times is good not because i think the
new york times is fair or worth reading
or worth the paper that it's printed on
but really just to throw it in their
face so any book that is ordered
up until week one up through week one i
should say
does count for that first
new york times bestseller week one list
so you can
do that if you would like oh and i
should tell you guys also before we get
going today uh that i am uh leaving
tomorrow morning we are pre-taping
tomorrow's dm it's a q a and you can
submit your questions at
reubenreport.locals.com we're going to
be pre-taping it right after today's
show tomorrow's show
pre-taped because i have to uh you know
this is tough for me to say
i'm going back to la for a day
actually less than a day i'm in and out
in a couple hours uh but
i'm taping
my fourth prageru video to coincide with
the launch of the book it's about the
ideas that are in the book so it'll come
out i think around launch week around
april 12th or so i am literally going to
la
i am going right to prageru
and then i think we're having a dinner
we're going to have a dinner i'm told
we're having a dinner and then i'm
getting the hell out of there i feel
like i'm going to be arrested when i get
off the plane honestly like i am not
looking forward to this
prageru is still in la you probably saw
my interview with dennis last week like
i'm working on getting dennis and the
crew out of there but yes i'm going to
los angeles i'll send you pictures of
the horror uh and if you want to get
questions in for tomorrow's pre-taped q
a you can go to report.locals.com okay
now let's get to it so today's theme
is uh a shift of what we've been doing
for the last two days here because of
course we had the state of the union and
it was just
an abject disaster i don't know how you
can describe it any other way and not
only was the content of the state of the
union a disaster but really everything
subsequently like the media reaction to
it
the moves that are still happening right
now that are seemingly escalating this
russian war it just all seems like
fabricated nonsense to me and then last
night i had the pleasure of going to a
fundraiser at uh gabe groysman's house
now he's the mayor of bal harbor which
is one of the little towns here in the
miami area let's throw the picture up
the fundraiser was for the guy that
you're seeing right there that's gabe to
the left and the other guy that's ron
desantis of course governor ron desantis
and there are about a hundred people
there nobody was wearing masks and it
was interesting because ron desantis
i felt gave a not only a great speech he
always gives a great speech i've now
seen him live a couple times
um but it was really a rebuttal
to the state of the union and then he of
course relates it in many ways to
florida
but it was like to listen to this guy
it's like oh that's the guy who should
be president now i've said it before i
want him to remain governor obviously he
has an election coming up and i
your governor to me is far more
important than the president of the
united states we've created a cult of
personality around the president so we
think that he's the king and whatever
the president wants is is what should we
should all bow to that's not the way
this whole thing is supposed to work
which is why the states now are so
vastly different a guy like me who left
california
to move to florida oh by the way i just
said
california and i mentioned that i'm
going to la so we're putting a little
money in the escape cali fund which
we're going to give to somebody at the
end of the year to get the hell out of
that dystopian crapple
um but he gave a really great speech and
it was making me think when i was trying
to come up with the idea for the show
today it's like let's talk about ways
that we can get out of this madness so
that is the focus today like the endless
bs from biden and fouchy and the media
versus
the actual correct way to deal about
things and we'll just show you one more
thing quick before and then i think
we're gonna throw to an ad real quick
but uh this is funny so here's biden the
day before
this is monday this is the day before
the state of the union we showed you
that video yesterday uh but that's biden
just walking alone in a field by the uh
oval office over there on the the
grounds of the white house and he's
alone and he's wearing a mask and you
know he has some sort of trouble walking
you can see he's really focused on the
way he walks okay fine that's monday
then on tuesday there he is at the state
of the union and look at that guy and
he's with all of these old people and
many of them are decrepid looking and if
you have seen the videos i mean a lot of
them were kissing him he was kissing
people bumping heads with a few people
like these are the same freaks who have
your kids still in masks in school now
in certain states and cities and then of
course here he is on wednesday mask back
on
with some other lady
mass back on none of it makes any sense
it's all drivel and theater and nonsense
and my
purpose of the show today
the purpose of the show today is to
figure out ways to move past it and i a
lot of that is directly related to ron
desantis and i know that's that's very
florida focused and obviously not all of
you guys are in florida but these are
things that can be modeled in other
states and i want to help give you the
tools to fight back so that's what we're
going to be doing today before i get to
any of that though i want to talk to you
about geniusel you know let me tell you
about jenny's cell's new ultra retinol
cream which uses dual action skin
technology to visibly reduce and improve
red inflamed and yes even blotchy skin
by combining hyaluronic there i said it
right acid and a breakthrough
phytoretinol you too
can smooth away forehead wrinkles and
laugh lines plus renew and revitalize
your appearance without the harsh
effects and irritation of retinol
geniusel ultra retinol is safe for
sensitive skin provides effective
hydration and skin renewing benefits for
all skin types and is perfect for both
men and women if after using you don't
see a visibly younger clearer complexion
in the mirror get a hundred percent of
your money back guaranteed and for a
limited time you can try genusell's
ultra retinol free with genusel's most
popular package save over sixty percent
on geniusel's top sellers right now and
get an extra 10 off when you enter my
special code dave at checkout
that's geniuselle.com dave jenyasel.com
dave all orders upgraded to free
priority shipping that's g-e-n-u-c-e-l
dot com slash dave januselle.com
all right so this is a great little
video from yesterday this is before the
event that i saw desantis speaking at
last night uh he is talking to a bunch
of uh south florida students and look
what happened right at the beginning of
the talk this is just spectacular
you do not have to wear those masks i
mean please take it off honestly it's
not doing anything and we got to stop
with this code theater so you want to
wear it fine but this is this is
ridiculous
all right well it's good to be at usf
it's just great because you don't have
to wear those masks if you want to wear
them fine but he's being a little
dismissive to the religion of masks as
we all
have to be at this point and again he
did not force anyone to do anything if
you want to find
i don't see any reason to do it choice
is up to you you guys are all 18 19
years old you look pretty healthy why do
you just
accept the orders of people who have
abused you for two years now of course
all the usual leftist blue check
lunatics on twitter we're saying he's an
evil authoritarian and he's trying to
kill people and we should wear masks
forever but what desantis did there not
only not only was it right in in
principle in terms of you do what you
want to do right he didn't force anyone
to do anything but it's also we we have
to get i think all of us now
the next step of this is we have to get
to a place where we're all going to be a
little more forceful in how we talk
about this stuff meaning they've abused
everybody for two years okay
destroyed your businesses depressed your
children masks on everything the speech
issues that kids are having all of the
stuff that we all now know
it's not just about okay now we're just
going to move on we need to start
pushing back a little bit harder i
really believe that so i think that was
i think it was just a really nice moment
and it was also just like a human moment
with desantis like he's done basically
everything right here and he's just
looking at these kids like what are you
doing that's the main takeaway there
he's looking what are you doing
take it off if you want to take it off
don't feel that you have to be just like
a robotic
slave
just don't do that but now we've got a
couple policies that desantis is putting
in place here in florida that i think
are the right policies that hopefully
will start spreading throughout the
nation
so here he is talking with surgeon
general joseph lapido who's also
been one of the great like advocates for
alternative treatments and anti-mandates
and all that stuff and they're talking
about new guidance for florida workers
simply relying on outdated cdc guidance
when the experience has completely
undercut that
is not really a reasonable thing to do
at this point and so this is the fresh
guidance and so for all the businesses
you know we are recommending officially
against
force masking policies particularly for
retail workers and for people working in
the services industry in our hospitality
industry every time i go to these places
i'll be in these big events and you have
all these people having such a good time
and the poor servers are force masks and
i will ask them are you allowed to take
the mask off they say not yet they're
all waiting for it they all want to be
liberated they want to be treated
normally and in florida yes this is
based on science and data but it's also
the case that when you have health
guidance that conflicts with the data
that has the effect of creating a
two-tiered society that is harmful as
well and you don't want to have
instruments of public health marginalize
different communities of people based on
their occupation or vaccination status
or anything like that so we're proud to
be leading the way yet again i think
this will make a positive impact and so
i want to thank you for uh for being on
the ball on this and putting out some
stuff that i really think
will help
an awful lot of people in the state of
florida and isn't it refreshing when you
just hear something true and good and
real and honest it's it's refreshing
like we're all swimming in such a river
of [ __ ] from the media and the
president and the cdc and everything
else but when you just hear someone say
i want people to be treated decently and
i want them to have choice and not be
abused
it's it's actually a breath of fresh air
it's like it's like a weight off of your
chest it really is
if you don't know more about surgeon
general joseph uh latipo you really
should we'll start doing some more clips
of him because he really uh
if i'm not mistaken desantis hired him
right before the pandemic can you
clarify that for me whether it was right
before the pandemic or it was right at
the beginning of the pandemic and the
guy has just been an absolute all-star
and it has nothing to do with the color
of his skin however if he was a lefty
uh surgeon general you'd know all about
him but you know we're not supposed to
talk about you know right leaning
conservatives they don't count as black
people but what he said there and by the
way i saw the same exact reaction on
twitter as i just referenced to what he
said to the kids is that oh no he's
using the government to force private
businesses to do things it's actually
not what is what he said if you listen
to it he said we are recommending
against forced
masked policies meaning
that right now even here in florida if
you go to big chain hotels for example
couple weeks ago i was at a hyatt in
boca raton
all of the employees are still wearing
masks the people behind the desks the
the women that are cleaning the room the
janitors etc etc they're all wearing
masks i i've mentioned this before but i
make it a point whenever i go anywhere
at this point restaurant elsewhere to
tell the people you don't have to wear
the mask for me you know when we have
the guys that come here and do some of
our landscaping stuff and they're
they're wearing masks and they're
outside i'm like guys you don't have to
do it they've stopped doing it at my
house that's that's my policy with these
people um because they're not less than
us just because you you work at a at a
hotel just because you work at a blue
collar job in the service industry etc
you should not be treated differently
and you can make the choices for
yourself again if you want to do it go
ahead and do it but desantis is totally
right because what this is creating is a
two-tiered system so when you see aoc
go to that ridiculous gala remember that
a couple months ago she goes to this
gala that was like 10 grand a pop in her
30 000 dress and you see her out there
with big smiles no mask and then you see
all the people all the servers
everywhere without masks uh or with
masks it's a problem because eventually
those people will start hating those
people and maybe that's what the whole
system wants it just wants us all to
hate each other uh latipo was hired on
september 22nd 2021 and he has just been
an all-star throughout so it wasn't
right at the beginning it was a little
bit further in um but anyway you can see
there are
there are good moments throughout this
covet hysteria and they are starting
here in florida so whether you're in
texas right now or new york it's like
there are
ideas that you can push forth that you
can talk about with your friends so that
hopefully they trickle up to some of the
people that are the elected officials
you know even in crazy new york now
there's a guy by the name of lee zeldin
who is now going to run against crazy
kathy hoechel kathy i call her kathy c
word okay and it's like i think we could
probably nudge that guy to open up even
more like there's real opportunity here
so let's see what happens all right
before we move on guys i want to talk to
you about roman you know when the moment
for intimacy arrives you need to be
ready it's true
roman ready whether you've been in a
relationship for years or you're just
getting started having the confidence
that comes from preparation means that
you're free to enjoy the moment when the
moment comes even though you are far
from ordinary the truth is that eb is
really common in fact 52 percent of guys
aged 40 to 70 experience some form of
erectile dysfunction with roman you can
get a free online evaluation and ongoing
care for erectile dysfunction all from
the comfort and privacy of your home a
u.s licensed health care professional
will work with you to find the best
treatment plan if medication is
appropriate it ships to you for free
with two day shipping roman system is
completely confidential and totally
discreet no big logos or labels on the
boxes get starting getting started is
simple just go to roman.com ruben and
complete an online visit the benefits of
ed treatment can help you reconnect with
your partner and rediscover the joy of
sex go to roman.com ruben today and if
you're prescribed to get 15 off your
first month of ed treatment make sure
you're ready to have confidence and
control this spring roman ready and now
back to
me okay so i just gave you some good
covert stuff right and the interesting
part of this of course is that if you
watch the state of the union you know we
did a big ukraine
state of the union very little about the
united states then at the end it was
like ah we're moving past kobe let's
forget about that we got a new thing to
worry about okay okay it's all a show
big shell game of ideas just to keep
people so that they can't really focus
on what's important basically um but
biden does that at the state of the
union then i showed you the image up top
then the next day he's wearing a mask
again after kissing all of these old
decrepit people the day before
and now his administration they're still
going on tv shows still pushing for more
masks and still with mandates kind of
etc etc
so here is health and homeland secretary
javier becerra he's on with chuck todd
and chuck
chuck really still loves masks and
abusing children
can we really move beyond mass until
everybody can get vaccinated is it fair
to say that the mass mandate on planes
the mass mandate and sort of the
on federal public transportation trains
we got we're going to keep it until
everybody from infant forward can get
vaccinated
yeah
chuck it's it's it's more
this is not a light switch you just
can't go on and off uh it's a matter of
doing this
knowing the science being thoughtful
about how we do this
you know you there will be people who
will continue to wear masks some have to
those who are immunocompromised are
under five year years of age children
still aren't vaccinated and so we still
have reason to be cautious but look
we're in a different place today and we
can move forward and we know what it
takes and we're putting the tools
together that medicine cabinet is a lot
more full
all right so everything becerra said is
just useless politician talk he just
said a bunch of nothing right like okay
fine the real issue here is chuck todd
what are you doing chuck todd on your
news program you have a msnbc show i
guess and then you've got your nbc show
on sundays what are you doing why are
you still
two years into this thing so excited to
have people wearing masks on planes and
trains and federal transportation i
suspect chuck todd that you probably
mostly
fly private you probably jump on a
private plane and don't wear a mask
i'm gonna guess that's what goes on with
you why is it that you would like
regular people who have to fly
commercial be abused that's what you'd
like so i will have to be abused in
effect tomorrow when i get on the plane
to go to los angeles
i will have to be abused i will slowly
drink small portions
of creamer throughout so that i can keep
my mass down as as much as possible
that's what i do you know just keep
drinking oh no no i'm drinking creamer
just a small amount of creamer
eating peanuts very soon you can't eat
peanuts you'll kill everybody now um
so what is the deal chuck todd why do
you want infants vaccinated how many
infants are spreading kovid to other
infants or their caretakers you never
give us the numbers these people still
can we talk about any of the side
effects are we allowed to talk about
that can you show me all the
peer-reviewed studies on what happens
when you inject
children and infants with these vaccines
have we studied this for years do we
really know what's going on there
they're just not good people they are
not good people the president of the
freaking united states this senile old
buffoon was basically trying to get us
past this and now the media is trying to
push it back in our lap it's actually
crazy speaking of crazy
the view you know this program this is
where these five lunatics uh
just scream at each other the whole time
uh well chelsea clinton who is the
daughter of failed presidential
candidate hillary clinton and rapist
bill clinton uh she was on there and uh
talking about how uh you know she's got
a kid and their kid's not vaxxed and uh
oh we're gonna have to figure out
something here now the last time you
were here well you weren't really here
it was zoom zoom and we were kind of
commiserating over the challenges of the
pandemic mental health kids being uh not
in school
socialization things that are kind of uh
you know that are falling out of the way
but what do you how do you feel like the
re-entry is especially on the heels of
seeing the state of the union with no
masks
are you feeling like normal is coming
back i mean even just back there i was
like do i hug do i not hug like i think
we're all just having to navigate
forward you know listening of course to
our public health authorities and also
what we think is the right answer for
our families you know i
have a two and a half year old who isn't
vaccinated yet and so that is still a
major factor for how our family thinks
about like where we're spending time i
also though i'm so thankful that my two
older kids are in school
um and thankfully have been able to be
in school and i'm so thankful to the
just really heroic teachers who are also
part of our front line essentially yes
i mean she's just an npc right she's
just a non-playable character who just
repeats the talking lines why does
anyone give a [ __ ] what chelsea clinton
thinks about anything right we have to
stop caring what politicians children
think of who do extraordinary things i
don't know that chelsea clinton's done
anything other than you know her parents
opened every door for her to to do
whatever it is that she does okay so
that that's one thing um she has an
unvaxxed two and a half year old so
she's not sure where to go
um and she's not sure who she can hug i
hug people people come up to me and hug
me all the time
i don't mind shaking hands i'll fist
bump you i'll hug you i don't like the
excessive hug you know some people they
hold on a little too long don't like
that kind of hug but just the hey how
you doing hug that's just fine these
people they they have allowed fear
to become the driving factor in their
life fear and control is what drives
them it should not drive you these are
paranoid
crazy people at this point and heck of a
segway there too speaking of paranoid
crazy people here's fouchy
a day after the ridiculous state of the
union where that 80 year old man was
hugging and kissing and sniffing hair
and everything else here's fauci saying
it's still too risky to unmask kids now
we could get lucky because the
trajectory right now is going way down
and it very well may be
that if you take masks off the kids in
the next week or so it's going to keep
going down but you've really got to be
careful you know you don't want to say
it's an absolutely wrong decision
it's understandable why people want to
take masks off the kids
but right now given the level of
activity that we have
it is risky
yeah just shut up man like enough enough
and don't worry guys you know i always
tell you that i try to do the positive
coveted stories i'm going to get to some
more de santa stuff in just a second but
i think it's i had to show you this
stuff because it's important to see how
the system seemingly was ready to move
on two days ago so it gives you this
like odd glimmer of hope and then two
days later fauci no we're gonna still
put the kids and again he never does the
numbers right it's never about the
numbers when it gets to the lowest point
that it's gonna get and we'd see the
trend going down then we could do this
or that or the other thing
please tell me this fouchy lord fauci
please tell me who is more at risk that
80 year old man with a bunch of other
geriatric people who were all on top of
each other applauding and clapping and
and all of that stuff versus a bunch of
young
five-year-olds in a classroom with a
teacher who's obviously vaxxed
tell me but you can't tell me because
this is all complete
nonsense and you know it uh speaking of
biden uh the daily wire had this little
funny clip it's only about 30 seconds
just showing how what biden said
during the state of the union about how
we have to heal and nobody's our enemy
and everything else that is just
complete [ __ ] just as per what he
said only a few weeks before take a look
there's no excuse
no excuse for anyone being unvaccinated
this continues to be a pandemic of the
unvaccinated so stop looking at covert
as a partisan dividing line
see it for what it is
a god-awful disease
let's stop sending each seeing each
other as enemies
and start seeing each other for who we
are
fellow americans
why are you the way that you are
i mean the most generous version of that
that you could give to biden is that he
just don't know doesn't know what he's
saying right that he just they put
something in front of him and he reads
and he just has no idea what he's saying
but look that was january of 2022 right
so it's you know five weeks ago he's
saying it's still a pandemic of the
unvaccinated and there's no reason for
anyone to be unvaccinated and the
implication is like you're gonna pay
somehow we're going to get you if you're
unvaccinated well joe i'm unvaccinated
what are you going to do to me what do
you are i mean really are we at the
point you're going to are you going to
close down my bank are you going to
arrest me like what are you going to do
i made the choices that were right for
me and i got coveted and i have natural
immunity by the way it's not just me
it's that scary joe rogan guy got
coveted has natural immunity there's
plenty of other people that made choices
for themselves but think about how just
divisive he was five weeks ago pandemic
of the unvaccinated complete lie we know
that vaccinated people get coveted
transmit covet etc etc um
and then what he says at the state of
the union the entire state of the union
was one
lie
after another just one endless lie after
another so now i tell you all of that
i'm bringing you on a roller coaster of
a show today right we started with
desantis some good stuff then i show you
the ridiculous media and the old buffoon
biden and now let's finish up with more
desantis how do you do it right how do
you fight the machine correctly and show
people there is a way out of this morass
of insanity uh well first here's a tweet
from ron desantis this is from two or
three days ago
he said last week the biden
administration requested the assistance
of state national guards to deploy at
washington d.c i have rejected this
request there will be no florida guard
sent to d.c for biden's state of the
union now this was obviously right
before the state of the union and biden
wanted uh all of these national guards
to show up and they put fences all over
the capitol and they wanted this big
army basically to be there to scare the
people now meanwhile nobody was there
did you see any videos did i miss
anything guys were there any videos of
mobs outside of the capital saying job
items mean
no but they want to show you they have
power you don't have power so desantis
said hey i'm the chief executive of this
state this is complete fabricated
nonsense you're trying to make it seem
like you're under threat because you
guys love being victims or at least
having people perceive you as victims
and i'm just not going to play the game
so it's absolutely spectacular
absolutely spectacular and speaking of
spectacular um
last week was uh national margarita day
a very important day for me
and uh desantis had some fun with that
too so my advice to everyone out there
who's frustrated sad angry pissed off
feel those emotions go to a kickboxing
class have a margarita do whatever you
need to do this weekend and then wake up
on monday morning we gotta keep fighting
having a margarita is well and good but
it is not a cure for bite inflation
okay little cheesy whatever maybe he
should have actually drank from the
margarita right there but you see the
point they ruin everything sake you
you've ruined the world as we knew it
and then it's like no go out there and
have them read it
it's like biden is the one that has
ruined this when i was listening to
desantis speech last night he was very
clear in how biden's policies have
increased inflation how they have harmed
the
supply chain how they have screwed us up
in terms of energy right now by closing
keystone and more so that we are now
watching gas prices go up and prices of
everything actually one of the people at
the event asked what i thought was a
really excellent question to desantis
about uh the house prices here in
florida because i can tell you with
someone that just bought a house house
prices are really high right so now on
one hand that's good because that means
more people with money are coming in
they'll hire more workers
it's all good but at some point you want
you want more competition so that house
prices go down and what he said was he
said we're actually in a bit of a bind
right now we have all of these new
people coming here so they're competing
for a limited set of houses and then
even though there's a crazy amount of
construction going on here in florida
and i can assure you when i walk clyde
almost every house in my neighborhood is
being knocked down or in some level of
construction because so many new people
are coming here and and i hope they will
vote the right way and i'll do
everything i can when i'm on dog walks
to make sure that they do
but he said there's not much we can do
at the moment at the state level in
terms of the cost of goods when a two by
four now costs four times what it costs
before so
that's an honest answer from a
politician like he can't control the
cost of everything um but what you can
do as he said is we can try to lower
taxes as much as possible we can try to
give as many incentives as possible for
builders to come here and build he said
we don't just give cash away we're not
going to do that sort of thing
but this all falls on the lap of joe
biden and the democrats who did all this
i'm sorry if that sounds partisan
but it's true
it's true desantis continued a couple
days ago at cpac in orlando and the
problem that we face as conservatives is
a lot of major institutions in our
country have become infected with this
woke virus you look at academia do we
even need to discuss that their main
objective now is to impose an
ideological world view on the people
that come through their universities you
look at corporate america they're
mentioning they're opposing voter id
many of them make a lot of money from
chinese slave labor but they don't want
voter id in the united states so they
are engaging in woke activism you look
at our bureaucracy and how totally off
the rails they have become in many
different agencies and it's not just
limited to people like fauci you have it
across the board where this has become a
major behemoth you look
at the corrupt and dishonest legacy
media in this country and what they're
doing to divide us and what they're
doing to prop up the regime they are not
in the business of telling the truth
they're in the business of spinning
partisan narratives to be able to
benefit their side they don't speak
truth to power they're defending the
regime in power and if you speak up they
come after you they'll smear you they'll
defame you all they do day after day is
concoct a blizzard of lies to try to
deceive the american people and make no
mistake that's going to intensify
leading up to november they're going to
try to think do anything they can to
relieve the blame off biden and to try
to fool the american people into keeping
democrats in office we're not going to
let them do it but that's what we're
facing and then maybe to top it off you
have big tech
here's where we're at when you have a
society that's veering away from the
truth
anybody that stands up and speaks the
truth will come under fire
you know it's funny as he said it's all
going to intensify as it leads up to
november the lights in the studio
actually flickered
it's a sign from the lord man
they've got all sorts of tricks up their
sleeves but you see why i did the show
the way i did it today because i think
everybody especially you guys watching
this right if we're roughly like-minded
and that's why you watch this thing it's
like i was kind of feeling depressed
sort of or it's not even exactly
depressed i was feeling just like
dejected about everything after the
state of the union because it was so
counter to the world as i see it the the
image that that guy put up of what the
world is was so reverse of what we're
all seeing and so many people swallow it
so
uh that's why i did the show the way i
did it today because i think it's
important to defend the people that are
fighting and trying to build something
properly and if we can all just
incorporate that in our own lives then
then we'll be in good shape hopefully
right like that's at least the hope for
the good shape couple comments from
reubenreport.locals.com
says i've seen kids walking to school
masked up and they are not close to
anyone and this is texas it makes me sad
yeah this is what they do you know this
is why you try to get kids young it's
why they're so obsessed with state
education and that they the educators
should know what to teach the kids and
it shouldn't be the parent's own stuff
because once they can break a young mind
man what they can do to you after that
and i was on vacation with my family
last week and i have a 12 year old
nephew who's awesome
and i was asking him what he thinks of
masks and all that he's like well we
have to do it it's just what it is i was
like well he's like but the teachers you
know they wear them down sometimes but
we get yelled at if we put him up and
you know the second we get out of school
we put him down and then we're
downstairs in a basement playing video
games together and then we go upstairs
because we got to go to you know soccer
practice and they make us put they all
know it's nonsense and that's a 12 year
old but god only knows what they have
done the long term psychological damage
that they've done to seven-year-olds
these kids are gonna do horrible things
to old people one day and they will most
likely deserve it jj says the view is on
a different planet than the one i live
on i agree i agree and i think we need
to just figure out the separation thing
that's sort of where i'm at kind of
mentally and physically at the moment i
don't want anything to do with these
people i really don't and i don't know
if that means i have to build a moat
around my house with some gators in it
and i'll get an iron dome system from
israel and just take care of business
over here and good people can come here
and party and hang out and drink tequila
if they want um but i just don't want
anything to do with these people they
live on another planet they're they're
destroying everything and and in many
ways actually this is sort of what my
book's about because we have to figure
out ways to disassociate from them and
defend the things that we care about
jeannie says the left is addicted to
being scared it makes them feel
righteous for some reason yes it's a
deep psychological trick right like if
you can keep people scared all the time
they will do almost anything in the name
of that fear in the name of defending
against whatever the fearful thing is
and that's what they've done so they had
four years of pretending that that
orange guy was hitler even though he
wasn't and now they had two years of
pretending we were all going to drop
dead over a disease that was 99 point
something nine something percent uh you
were going to recover
but they love fear it gives them power
it feeds them fear
fear leads to the dark side somebody
said that uh guys reminder on this world
book day you can pre-order don't burn
this country at daverubin.com
book and if you do it
at any time up until april 12th and then
that whole week actually that counts as
week one new york times sales and i'm
going to expose them like they put me on
last time they put me way lower than i
was supposed to be but i just want to
throw it back in their faces like i
don't care about the new york times list
i honest i truly do not care i am not
being
that's not like a fake humble thing or
something like that i don't care i was
glad to get on the first time because
it's a it's a little feather in the cap
or something and and you know i work
with people in the publishing world and
my agents and things who it's important
to them it helps them get promotions
that's just how the world operates i
don't care this time at all but i would
love to just expose the new york times
list for what it is like let us sell a
gajillion books and let them not put me
on it not because you're not going to
believe this sales they can look at the
numbers there's actual numbers and they
release them so when they lie to you
about the news in the new york times all
the time sometimes it's hard to track it
sales are pretty easily trackable
so anyway you can go to davereuben.com
book and i promise you you're going to
dig the book i i really think it's it's
really good and we're putting out this
prageru video that week as well uh that
will go into some of the ideas in the
book and yeah we've got some surprises
oh and i'm going on a book tour which
will announce the full schedule sometime
next week but we're going to be bouncing
around very heavy here in florida and
we're going to figure out some other
cities to get to and all that good stuff
reminder
you can submit your questions for
tomorrow's pre-recorded direct message
because i got to go to la to go to
prageru for an hour
here's some money for the
fund
get out of la fund
uh so you can submit questions right now
at
rubinreport.locals.com part two of my
interview with harriet hageman she is
the republican running against liz
cheney in wyoming part two is up right
now on youtube and rumble and up ad free
at
reubenreport.locals.com
that is all i have for you today i feel
this was a complete show you can now go
about your day and i'll see you tomorrow